pivot to the baltimore ravens there was
a report from the boston globe over the
weekend that the ravens and quarterback
lamar jackson have begun contract
negotiations and the two sides are far
apart i'm told they haven't started
talking and one of the reasons i haven't
started talking
we don't know who the side is for lamar
jackson he's never had an agent is he
going to handle this himself his
mother's been his business manager is
she going to handle it is there someone
else that's going to get involved until
they know exactly who they're going to
be dealing with they haven't begun
talking to lamar jackson i hey
lamar jackson mvp in 2019
great player but
especially after what happened just over
the past few weeks with jared goff and
carson wentz guys who got big market
value contracts after three seasons in
the nfl yeah
i'm willing to give it another year if
i'm baltimore and i know it's going to
make it more expensive next year than it
would be this year but i don't want to
be the next one where people like you
and me are saying right you guys should
have waited you guys should have waited
i hear you broken the bank for lamar
jackson until you had a better sense
that this was something that was going
to be sustainable because it wasn't
sustainable for goffin wentz is it going
to be sustainable for guys like jackson
baker mayfield falls into that category
too i think the browns should wait and
just make sure that they they are are
sold on what they have before they
they sign a contract that is going to be
a major pain in the butt to deal with i
i hear you with all those points i i do
and i think they're real i guess where
i'd push back just a little is i would
go i do think lamar jackson is more
special than wentz or jared goff all
right that would be just the first thing
i say you know he's he's a special
talent and now he does it a different
way and we know all that but here's the
other aspect i think where
you know lamar has a little bit more
power than maybe even those guys did
and because yeah they got to be a little
careful again because the way he plays
it only takes one hit or one you know
wrong run and everything like that and
everything can change so they definitely
you know that that's a gonna be a topic
they have to discuss but the other thing
where lamar has a little power in in my
mind is
man
they've gone all in on the lamar jackson
offense right so if you abandoned ship
on lamar you know now or next year it's
going to be a year or two before you're
going to be able to kind of
reorchestrate your team and your offense
again for the next quarterback
and that's where i think lamar has a
little power in this situation because
they've done everything with the tight
ends and the running backs on the
offensive line they pushed it in the
middle of the table and said we're going
to play a certain style of football it's
different than the rest of football
nobody else is going to do what we do
because we have this guy
around him yes but i and and here's the
temptation if you're the ravens if you
end up negotiating with a guy who's not
represented by an experienced and
skilled agent there are plenty of ways
where the devil on your left shoulder
will be tempting you to try to take
advantage of the situation because the
guy you're negotiating with doesn't
understand all of the nuances the little
things right the traps in the
contractual language how far do you want
to go in helping him out to be a good
partner how far do you want to go in
sticking it to him because you can i
think back to the first contract that
russell okung negotiated for himself
with the broncos it was horrendous the
richard sherman contract and and i i
know that he would beg to differ and he
would differ loudly it was not a good
contract for him it should have paid him
a hell of a lot more when he was
performing at a high level under it and
it wasn't hey the nflpa had to get
involved and save the 49ers can we uh
can we do so can we move a few things
around here that that doesn't happen
typically so when you when you represent
yourself
there is a real temptation for the team
to take advantage of the situation would
the ravens i've on the ravens i i don't
want to get to a point where two three
four years from now lamar jackson does
hire an agent and the agent explains to
lamar jackson all the ways his team
screwed him yeah i i i hear you and uh
we'll see it is it's gonna be an
interesting contract to how they figure
this out because they do have to protect
themselves certainly you know at some
point
lamar jackson
is not gonna be able to run to the
capacity we've seen him run
you know these last few years which is
just absolute lightning in a bottle
michael vick we've never seen anything
like this it's the greatest running
quarterback in the history of football
that discussion's ended it's over
but you know there is a time here where
you know they're not going to be able to
ride that horse as far as that type of
style of play with him and everything
and he's going to have to grow as a
passer and we've seen that he is growing
there's no doubt about it and i think
the next step too just along that you
know just getting back to their team a
little bit is you know receiver play and
what can they do an offensive passing
game can they expand that a little bit
we talk a lot during the year you know
they just it can be a little predictable
and it doesn't lend itself to a lot of
easy throws and things like that for
lamar jackson either so he's got to grow
i think they got to help him grow a
little bit more with more ideas in the
past game and things like that and hey i
like their tight ends we know that uh
hollywood brown did show up a little bit
last year you know finally but i still
think they need another guy out there to
to help him out and help that aspect of
his game and their offense grow all
together
well and what did they start doing they
started coming up with creative ways to
get the ball hollywood brown's hands
other than run down the field and get
open yeah right in the backfield a
little flip here there was there was i
remember that one play it was almost a
disaster but you're right working he a
lot of those you know the little flip
went awry but he got it and off he goes
and and we need that more and more teams
need to do that the best offenses come
up with ways to get the ball in the
hands of their playmakers and not just
simply say go get open and that's what
the ravens need to do to make it
attractive for other receivers to want
to come be part of what they have
cooking there offensively and
defensively and speaking of defensively
pass rushers available in free agency
yannick gawkway matthew judo and i guess
they could tag judon again at a 20 raise
i think it's almost 19 million i
wouldn't do that him again no way who
comes back who comes back i i gotta
think you know judon i like him as a
player i i don't think i could ever
sleep at night if i was a gm and i was
paying matthew judon 19 million dollars
a year he's really he's a solid player
love him on his team you know he's got
attitude he's physical but to me he's
not a top tier pass rusher in football
by any stretch of the imagination that
way you know yannick and gawkway is the
guy i look at hey listen the one thing
that i look at the baltimore ravens on
the defensive side of the ball
the another secondary is awesome
the front seven of course is very good
and just the one adjustment you'd like
to see there is hey they're big and
physical we know that they need some
speed guys on the d-line they need some
disruption guys and i think that's why
they went out and made that trade for
yannick and gawkway last year they need
some of that you know they've been one
of the slower front teams in football
over the last few years and that that to
me is where i if i'm them i'd favor
yannick and gawkway uh yanikan
over over a matthew judon
yeah and uh look
he flashed he was disappointing all in
all last year and uh he's gonna be one
of these guys i think that hits the
market and we'll see it's fascinating
this year to try to figure out who's
going to make the plunge and pay some of
these guys with the capsicum it really
is you're out there how many of these
big deals are we going to hear about
early in free agency it's only a couple
of weeks away
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports